kilómetros, 1.020 metros de ancho.
¿Usted quiere saber cómo se juntaron ellos?
Es una historia bastante grande.
Mi mamá, Ana, tenía un hermano en Ciudad Plataba.
Como gente dijeron que yo no conocía ella como soltera, cuando me encontró que muchos
caballeros quisieron a ella, preguntaron, mamá, ¿todavía está linda como era?
Yo no conocía cómo era.
Hoy usted va a conocer una hija mía, un poquitico, parece mi mamá que descansa, entonces usted
se va a dar cuenta cómo era mi mamá.
Mi mamá tenía un gran poder.
¿Poder?
Cuando llevaron mi papá para militares, la guerra, 1905, la guerra con Japón, ella se
quedó con otros hijos.
Sin posibilidad la vida, pues estaba muy, muy bajo en Ciudad, en pobreza, y ella levantó
sus hijos, cuatro hijos.
Luego pronto viene mi papá de la guerra, así me dijo, estoy diciendo que me dijo mi
mamá, es Ana, vamos a buscar una hija, y entonces no fue un hijo más, no fue una hija.
Nació ese muchachito que está sentado al frente de usted, y nació, como yo les digo
el 20 de marzo de 1902.
En 1914 empezó la guerra, Alemania atacó a Rusia.
Usted sabe que Polonia está entre dos paredes, en un lado Rusia, y en otro lado Alemania,
y siempre está en el centro.
Me acuerdo como Rita, en 1914, entró a Alemania con aviones, y bombearon la ciudad, y toda
la ciudad estaba en fuego.
Ese era el viernes en la noche.
Yo tenía una tía, hermana de mi papá, Raquel, Raquel Mesh.
Mi mamá que descansa, era más chiquitico, tenía dos años, tumbó en la mesa, agarró
un mantel, y metó ese mantel, me puso en la espalda, y corriendo para el búnker,
el único búnker que era en Ciudad Moldava, tenía mi tío Moisés Mesh, el esposo de Raquel.
Era hermano de mi mamá.
Yo no sé, o Dios quiso así, o suerte así, eso no puedo explicar, yo saco mi cabecita
de mantel, y la veo que toda la ciudad era en fuego, cielo rojo.
Allá empezó la amargura de mi vida de dos años, hambre, miseria, quemado.
Ya, ustedes tienen que saber cómo son alemanes, destruyeron todo.
Así, con hambre, con frío, el mundo sigue, el tiempo corre.
Voy a hacer un brinco.
Cuando yo tenía cuatro años, era un alemán, se llamaba Jude, era como, vamos aquí, mire
como gobernador aquí, y él gustaba mucho flores, alemanes gustan mucho flores.
Usted sabe que en Polonia, en mayo, hay muchos plantas de agua, y allá crecen flores amarillos.
Entonces, él llamaba a todos esos muchachitos, no solo a mí, todos los amiguitos, y dijo
así, vayan, busquen flores que me traigan, y cada uno reciba algo.
Usted sabe esa alegría, cuando hay hambre, y qué significa que da algo para comer.
Quiere 40, 70, 50 muchachitos, no puedo ustedes decir exacto, y cada uno trajo una mano,
y él dio un pedacito de pan, en esta forma, así, así, y así, cada uno.
Das ist zum Fressen, qué significa, es para comer.
Todo, dijo en palabras finas, como gentleman, no con grosería, zum Fressen, en alemán,
es una cosa, no muy agradable.
Y eso todo, quedó en mi agravado.
Después de cuatro años, se lo vieron que no hay posibilidad de ser un ciudadano, sufrieron
para el pueblo británico, y encontraron, adonde eran curas, eran muchas casitas.
¿Quién se fue?
Mi papá, con dos hijos, yo y dos hijos me quedaron con mamá en ciudad brutal.
Ellos conseguiron, usted sabe que curas, en Polonia, son muy valeriosos, no hay quien
derecho a casarse, y cada tenía uno, se llamaba clipbaña, se llamaba clipbaña,
y se consiguió un partico, seis por cuatro.
Allá se acomodó mi papá, con dos hermanos.
Ya consiguieron conocer un poquito a campesinos, ya dije, venga a trabajar, damos un poquito
de papa, un poquito de harina, ya era, que comer.
Yo tuve que estar con mi mamá, pues mi mamá tenía una hermana, y lo daba, tenía una
casita, como se dice, seis por ocho, se quedó.
¿Cómo se llamaba la hermana?
Pesa, se llamaba.
Y tenía una hija, se llamaba Frado.
¿Y los dos hermanos que se quedaron con usted, cómo se llamaban?
¿Los hermanos que se quedaron con usted y su mamá?
Se quedaron tres, Penejas, que está aquí, mi hermano mayor, y Erso, se fue con papá.
Se quedó Einar, Yedale, y yo.
En un mes, papá llamó, que viene uno más.
Se fue Einar, ya estaban ya tres.
Un mes más, ya se fue el otro, ya quedaron cuatro, y mi mamá era contra eso.
¿Por qué era contra eso?
Ella dijo, mi papá se llamaba Samuel, los hijos hay que criar en una ciudad grande.
Como todo malo que es, era una ciudad que pasó a revivir.
Entonces, mi papá regresó, ya tenía un caballo, una, con cuatro huellas, una...
Carreta.
Carreta virgen.
Y era el plan que se va muy profundo para Rusia.
Se puso ese caballo, con todo.